yeah
[Music]
home
home
yeah
yes
yes
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the ending of for all mankind
season 3 and this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't seen episode 10
yet back in episode 6 mars mission
commander danielle poole is talking
about her experience for people back on
earth she says i think it's a primal
urge in all of us the need the drive to
explore it doesn't matter how old you
get human beings are always going to
want to see what's over that next hill
and that is a big part of what this
show's about there's a moment in the for
all mankind season 3 finale where
president of the united states ellen
wilson invokes jfk when she tells her
vice president we didn't do these things
because they are easy but because they
are hard she's defending nasa and space
exploration in general while he's
defending the republican party from
things like gay astronauts and a
russian-american love child the bp is
there because her closeted gay husband
convinced her that having him on the
ticket would help her gain vital
political influence and he wants her to
resign because when faced with a scandal
over an affair by that same husband she
came out publicly as gay it's all rather
complicated and difficult and it's just
one of the many things that happened to
jeopardize future space exploration in
season 3. one thing that for all mankind
has always shown us is that for as
difficult as it is to go to space it's
worth it it's given us a cast of
complicated characters willing to put
themselves on the line to make that
happen and a timeline that's changed
enough to make it believable that these
projects could still exist by the end of
this season we have three space programs
working together in the middle of a
disaster on mars and it feels like it
all might be coming to an end the
sacrifices the problem solving the
setbacks the highs of people being their
best for something bigger than their own
survival all the things that make a show
like this so engrossing it's all hard
and if there isn't the right people and
the will to keep it going then it all
could be cast into the dustbin of
history by the time we get to episode 10
that will is starting to deteriorate and
just like it is in ellen's presidency
the future is uncertain the other thing
the show tries to show us is that when
you put aside the personal beliefs the
politics the prejudices and the natural
competition of things people do
generally come together to triumph in
the face of adversity the early part of
season three was about the three-way
race to mars between state agencies nasa
and ross cosmos and the upstart private
firm helios the accelerated timetable
and the effort to get there first leads
to several problems once they get there
and in the end none of them even have
the distinction of getting there first
instead the lone survivor of a secretly
manned north korea mission lee jong-gil
became the first man to step foot on the
red planet the finale opens with a
montage of his arrival and his lonely
existence trying to make contact with
home i wasn't sure about the feasibility
of him being there or what it would lead
to but regardless watching these few
minutes helped to remind us of how
difficult this all is and for what it's
worth i think they made a case that it
is in fact possible even if it was
unlikely that he'd be able to survive
he's unable to make contact with earth
and he eventually makes peace with the
fact that this is a one-way trip and
he's about to take his own life when
rover one shows up his hardware turns
out to be more essential than he is but
this does have the potential to
complicate things if mars does become
colonized
the fact that he's there doesn't become
a priority because the astronauts on
mars already have one kelly's condition
has gotten worse and the doctor says
they have a 24-hour window to get her to
the phoenix to deliver the baby or they
could both die everyone at the base and
everyone on earth is working on the
problem because they have too much
weight and not enough fuel the solution
for the weight problem is that everyone
besides kelly will stay behind she
objects to this but one by one all the
crew members volunteer in the first of
many uplifting moments peppered
throughout the finale it'll be rough but
if they implement strict rations and
their crops continue to produce they
should be able to survive the year and a
half that it'll take for sojourner 2 to
get there and bring them home the fuel
problem is more complicated because they
still only have enough to get 95 percent
of the weight of the phoenix the problem
is going to require some out of the
thinking to solve and as they're working
it margot notices elena is distracted
she pulls her aside for what will be
their last one-on-one conversation she
explains that she already knows about
the fbi investigation and when asked she
promises that she'll explain why she
helped the soviets later because right
now they need to focus on the problem at
hand because there's lives to save what
elena doesn't know is that her mentor
found out about this when the head of
ross cosmos miss catish came to offer
her a way out because of the way things
work out in the end it's not entirely
clear if margot intended to explain what
happened or not but the promise of that
is enough to get elena's focus where she
needs it to be when they return she
comes up with the idea to make kelly the
second stage and to have her propel
herself the rest of the way to phoenix
they'll strap what's called a pmu to her
which is essentially a jet pack with all
the extra fuel tanks and everything else
that they have on hand to give her the
extra push she needs to make orbit
there's a great moment after she
introduces the idea where she gets asked
the question i'm sorry are you
suggesting we light kelly baldwin up
like a rocket and she just gives the
deadpan answer basically ed lays out the
plan to kelly and in doing so does a
great job to explain things to us as
we're watching the other part of it is
that she'll have to be on top of the
ship so he'll have to pilot it and that
means he'll have to try to land with
almost no fuel the way this conversation
plays out it makes you fear that ed may
be signing up for his last mission of
course he would never let anyone else do
this he wants to give his daughter an
unborn grandchild the best chance they
could have and you do get the sense that
he'd be okay with making the ultimate
sacrifice if it came to that he puts the
best face he can on it and assures her
that he's got the best pilot he knows to
help them out he's talking about molly
cobb who hasn't played a large role in
the season i assume this is due to the
actor having scheduling conflicts and
while i would have liked to see more of
her the absence really added to the
impact of her walking into mission
control she gets a standing ovation
which she quickly quiets down before
asking to speak to the queen of darkness
it's a great full circle moment when
margot greets her there is history here
molly tried to pull a power move when
margot was out of town she came back and
fired her but after the tension's been
established they quickly get to work
it's nice to see things fall back into
place for everyone to be where they're
needed and doing what they do and they
even address their initial argument when
molly says ed wanted someone there who'd
had their ass on the line because this
was such a big dispute throughout the
season there was this question of who
was the better choice for commander and
to this point danielle had shined in
that role but in the end when it's all
hands on deck ed skills also proved to
be indispensable and he even got to show
off the language skills he picked up
during the war when he's the only one
who can talk to the north korean and the
acting and everything i just mentioned
was absolutely top shelf molly's
entrance and her attitude margo's
reaction and the little smile that ed
had on his face before he revealed that
he could speak korean
while the press is assembling to report
on this mission jimmy and his nasa anon
friends park a man outside jsc they give
him a task that he doesn't go through
with and when he returns he realizes
they're not there to steal another
statue he gets spooked after he sees
some weapons in the van he tries to call
amber who doesn't pick up and they knock
him out and tie him up karen manages to
get looped into this storyline when
amber calls her after she listens to
jimmy's message and the type of sequence
we've come to expect in the for all
mankind season finale we watch as all
the different stories reach their
conclusion simultaneously danny tries to
volunteer to pilot the m sam over his
guilt for the mining disaster when ed
brushes him off he admits that it wasn't
just that he was high or it was an
accident but that he chose not to act
because he was angry and a mess ed
rightly tells him he won't put his
daughter's life on the line so that he
can try to absolve himself he sends him
a way to do his job and promises him
there'll be a reckoning when it's over
at jsc margot goes up front and
addresses everyone working in mission
command only she knows it will be the
last time she'll ever do this and
there's an added layer that aleda is the
only other person that knows about the
fbi investigation she brings up being
there for apollo 11 and gene kranz's
words the future is ours to fight for
and when she says he was right then and
he still is today and then breaks a
little when she tells the crew what an
honor and privilege it's been to work
with all of them they cheer thinking
she's just talking about this mission
but we see that elena realizes this is
the last time she'll see margot do this
when she hands the room over to her we
know this is a real passing of the torch
when she walks out there's so much
history that pours in it's a bittersweet
end for someone who really did give her
whole life to the space program we had
seen that the intelligence services
managed to get sergey and his family out
of the ussr in a video call and know
that for all her efforts she won't be
able to outrun the consequences of her
mistakes she goes back to her office and
plays the piano and we cut to happy
valley getting ready to strap kelly to
the top of the m sam we see that she's
wearing a modified version of alexey's
suit there's a last minute exchange of i
love use between her and ed and then
there's just an absolutely perfect bit
of television it looks amazing the music
puts you right there with her and even
though i never feared that they might
kill kelly and her unborn child the
satisfaction of her knowing she's going
to make it when you see her smile as she
approaches the phoenix is short-lived
because ed still has to manage a
ballistic descent i must have watched
this 10 times now and from the moment
she separates to the smile stretching
across her face to ed's relief knowing
that no matter what happens next he got
his daughter to safety it gets me every
single time there's no time even to
process that though because karen is
outside of jsc and when she tries to
call jimmy's phone she notices that his
friends have it she'll find him tied up
in the back of the van and see that it's
filled with explosives when the
terrorist sees her he detonates the bomb
remotely and it destroys the building
and kills her jimmy survives to find her
in her last moments inside mission
command we see molly helping survivors
get out later we'll learn that she will
also lose her life while she's doing
that elada goes looking for margot and
finds that half of her office was
sheared off in the blast as the camera
pulls out to show the devastation we
presume that she thinks that margot was
killed on mars ed survived his crash
landing and is able to walk away from it
unfortunately when he returns to happy
valley danielle has to tell him that
karen died we get closing shots of elena
and her family at ground zero kelly on
the phoenix with her newborn danny is
exiled to the north korean ship to live
away from the others while they wait for
sojourner too ellen goes to see pam we
get a shot of sergey to see that he's
settling into his new life in america
and then we jump to 2003
where we see margot in a moscow
apartment by herself everything is in
its right place by radiohead plays as
she looks out the window and the season
comes to an end
season 3 was about going further than
humans have ever gone before in our
timeline the race made it possible to
get there but also set things up for
disaster as humans we're in a situation
where wherever we go we bring our
problems with us and that is fertile
ground for drama and i think what stands
out about this finale is that while
everything i said at the beginning holds
true that drive to explore the
difficulty of that the complications and
events that could conspire to bring it
all down in an instant in the end people
can come together and try not just to
overcome the adversity but build
something brand new together in the end
there's a short voice over with elena
recounting the voyage of the mayflower
as it focuses in on happy valley base
that thing that's been born out of the
disaster of the race to mars she says
what was once a group of strangers
voyagers seeking a better life had
become something different something
more and in the unlikeliest of places
they found a new home that's the bit of
hope that this show which is essentially
a sequence of near disasters just can't
shake going into this final episode it
was hard to imagine how we might get
further missions to mars and now the
rest of the crew who made it out have a
year to survive and to start the first
colony on the red planet that's the kind
of thing that this show does that i keep
coming back for this had some amazing
moments like you'd expect but i like
this finale slightly less than season
2's for a couple of reasons the show has
a way of introducing things that can
feel insignificant at the moment but
then circle back around and deliver a
big payoff i mean most of the latest
story in the first season felt like an
interesting but unconnected side story
and now it all makes a lot of sense
season 3 still had a lot of that going
on i think ed's story is the best
example i saw grown men crying in the
comments because their favorite space
program avatar wasn't the first person
to land on mars but i think that only
added to the ending which was about him
redeeming himself as a father sure not
being first on the moon is something
that's haunted him but as we learned
when he was buried in the hab so was the
way he left things with shane before he
died for him to be there and be
essential in kelly making it to safety
on the phoenix and to know that he was
okay with sacrificing himself if it came
to that makes him come out of this
season as even more of a boss and he got
to do what he does best and live to tell
the story margot and elena also had a
fantastic season even though it was hard
to watch at times there are obvious
parallels to her mentor von braun but we
understand her character much better and
can see how she ended up where she did
while knowing that her intentions were
mostly pure she put everything she had
into making space exploration what it is
in this timeline and that little bit of
her human nature she indulged in falling
in love led to places she couldn't come
back from elena will be a great
replacement though and it was fitting to
have her final act in the usb getting
sergey and his family to safety
karen and molly's deaths hit
unbelievably hard although molly's was
almost a blink and you'd miss it
situation the way the camera lingered on
the man she saved watching her walk back
into the smoke stood out but if i hadn't
paused to look at the paper i might not
have put things together in my first
watch when i finished i honestly
wondered how many people might miss that
karen's death felt like a complete shock
which i guess was the point and i
suppose if you think about it her arc
was complete when you have a show that
moves so quickly through time it makes
sense to deliver these dramatic endings
rather than have these great characters
just sort of fade away but one minute
she was about to step into the ceo role
at helios and the next she's just gone
both of the actors here gave great
performances they brought these
characters to life in a way that they're
both really memorable and they're gonna
be missed and geez my thoughts are
really just with wayne after the way
this played out i loved how they came
together and how molly gave her the i'm
a selfish prick speech that added to her
hero's ending and aligned her with the
show's thesis yeah she has been a prick
at times and that's been fantastic to
watch but she's also been selfless when
she needed to be and that's what she's
doing in her final moments i've been
critical of both jimmy and danny's
stories this season so i don't want to
beat a dead horse but in case you
haven't been following along in my
opinion these were the weakest elements
of this season they did manage to make
danny's situation more sympathetic but
only after they exhausted me with the
whole thing his bad behavior did add a
lot of tension along the way but i
mostly just wanted him to go away for it
rather than wanting to see him come back
around and redeem himself the banishing
seems like a fitting ending for how
things played out but it's a temporary
one that feels a little dangling since
we know that it'll be in the past by the
time the next season starts and i do
want to mention that even though i
didn't like a lot of what they gave him
to do casey w johnson did a great job in
the hab and in that last moment where he
comes to ed to salvage something with
his performance it's a little bit worse
with jimmy because i'm not even sure how
we're supposed to feel about that he
didn't know what his friends were up to
and you can see how he was sucked in but
what happens next is he the lone
survivor do they try to pin it on him or
does the fact that he has hero parents
and that he was a victim in all this
mean that nothing happens to him that he
just turns things around and that's what
we're going to be seeing next time i
honestly don't know and this is a part
of the bigger problem i had with this
ending i like the hope and i like that
space exploration will continue because
of this series of unexpected events to
bring things full circle there's the
parallel of ellen saying maybe the
republican party needs some destroying
and the fact that jsc is literally
destroyed in an attack that has a lot of
similarities to the oklahoma city
bombing in our timeline sometimes it's
in the reaction after a crisis or
catastrophe where change can happen but
there are a lot of things left up in the
air so it doesn't feel as neat it
doesn't have that feeling of everything
falling into place that you got at the
end of season two and to be fair that's
a pretty high bar so by no means am i
saying that this wasn't enjoyable or
that it was bad the highs were
absolutely high and that's enough to
keep me coming back when it's doing what
it does best there really isn't anything
else like it on tv i guess we'll have to
wait and see how they handle the
transition to know if it'll make sense i
had been worried about the lack of
likable new characters and i do think
that kelly and will certainly are a good
starting point for season four deb ended
up having a pretty satisfying arc by the
end of the season and with karen out of
the way i'm sure we're gonna see more of
him everyone else is getting old a
little too old and that makes it feel a
little slim but hey with margot in
moscow we'll finally get to see things
from the soviet perspective which is
something that's been lacking in this
show and we'll get a ton of new
characters there it is something to look
forward to and i think that's a great
place to leave things
let me know in the comments what you
thought about season three overall what
you thought about the finale and what
you're hoping to see in season four
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon